stephen burton 86 what are the odds that
matthew stafford actually ends up in
indianapolis everything i hear
uh-oh fans with sources says that
ballard wants him and that stafford
wants to come to
indy i've yet to hear that but hey the
cults need a quarterback stafford's
available
the question is what do the lions want
for him and
uh i think it would make sense i they
won't
be dramatically worse and they could be
significantly better with stafford
instead of philip rivers shireen
i certainly think he fits there mike he
fits what they want to do he fits frank
reich's offense and he could be there
for more than one year as a bridge
quarterback so
a lot depends like you said on what the
lions want for him what are the colts
willing to give up
for him they didn't have to give up
anything to get phillip rivers they just
had to sign him to a contract and
frankly it was a team-friendly deal that
they got with
phillip rivers last year so here they
are looking for a quarterback again but
i think it makes a lot of sense
i don't know that i'd say 25 million
dollars for phillip rivers at that point
his career was team friendly especially
when brady got 25 million as well
i thought it was more ski mask contract
for philip rivers but hey you know
reasonable minds can differ here's
another one jemon javian
asks do you think matthew stafford needs
to go somewhere with the dome stadium
because he's been playing in one or
would it be no problem if he goes to
denver now look i'd have to do
a full analysis on his statistics
playing outside versus inside but
every quarterback wants to play in a
dome if they can i think it just makes
it
attractive it's just one of the when you
list the pros and cons one of the pros
that you check is dome stadium right
yeah and you talk about lamar jackson
remember we were writing those stories
he's never played in a snow game in his
life he hadn't even seen
snow until he got to louisville and they
had a snowball fight but he never played
in it there and so
a lot of these quarterbacks had never
played in snow i don't know how many
snow games matthew stafford has played
in he grew up here in dallas
he didn't play in many if it any snow
games in high school he went to georgia
he didn't play in many if any snow games
coal games and georgie either so he
hasn't played in a ton of those mike
but i don't know that necessarily
matters i think quarterbacks can adjust
and then go where they where they need
to go everyone would rather play in a
dome i'm sure he would rather play in
indianapolis than
somewhere in denver maybe as far as
conditions go
but you just want to go and have a
chance to win wherever that is
best place for him i think is a spot
that has strong veteran leadership
not relying upon the quarterback to
provide it strong coaching
not relying upon the quarterback to
provide it and coaching that is strong
enough to elevate the quarterback
because i've never gotten the impression
he craves the mantle of being a leader
that's been the one flaw in his game
and and you really have to be picky to
find that but he's a great passer great
quarterback and
could make a team great next year
bennett virginia could you see the
texans and the packers
swapping quarterbacks aaron rodgers for
deshawn watson shireen what'd you think
of that
oh that would be so awesome to me but i
couldn't see
why aaron rodgers would possibly want to
go to the texans i mean you look at what
deshaun watson did with the texas this
year
he led the league in passing yards and
look what it got him four wins they are
not
close to being a super bowl champion but
i think that would be exciting to watch
i think deshawn watson would be terrific
in green bay
the over under on
aaron rodgers saying to jackie used to
be get the
expletive deleted out of my face would
be three and a half seconds
so for that reason alone i want the
trade to happen
uh pft pm policy what was wrong with our
boy blue during yesterday's game that's
a reference obviously to bill's
quarterback josh allen
for what did the chiefs defense do that
had him so rattled
and out of sync i look i think it was a
combination of the moment plus the
chief's defense is pretty good chris
jones seemed to be everywhere that i saw
josh allen
yesterday and he just he just was off
and they've got a great secondary
very underrated great pass rush very
underrated
we we talk about mahomes and tyrique and
kelsey and
it's all offense offense offense the
chiefs have a pretty good defense and
the bills
walked right into the teeth of it
yesterday
yeah and you look at josh allen's
elevation mike
he went from getting the bills to the
to the playoffs last year and they lost
to houston they shouldn't have
this year he gets some wins he gets them
to the championship
game they've taken another step i think
next year they'll be expecting to take
that
next step which is get to the super bowl
and he's taken all those steps
mahomes lost his first time in the afc
championship game too now they should
have won the game as we said earlier
but he did lose his first one i think
it's all about taking those steps and
learning how to win and i think he did
that this year but he didn't look good
in that game for sure
there has been a real buzz in league
circles people who study the game people
who are at the games people who see josh
allen play
were questioning whether or not alan has
caught patrick mahomes now
that's regular season mahomes and
regular season
allen there is something about playoff
ma homes
that rises to another level and you know
you think about this every week
of the regular season the chiefs are
taking the absolute
best punch that the opponent has they
are the measuring stick the chiefs are
week in and week out
it becomes exhausting and then you get
to the playoffs
it's full focus it's next level and
that's what we saw from the homes
yesterday and josh allen
simply wasn't able to meet that level of
performance sharing
yeah and i saw uh tony dungy tweet this
out
mahomes they're averaging 36.1
uh points in the postseason games he's
started and finished
they've had he's had 15 drives in the
postseason
this year seven touchdowns four field
goals and missed phil go
one punt and two kneel downs this
offense
rolls when they get to the postseason
and they're doing it again mike
last one real quickly from nelly with
the why should the nfl have eliminated
the two weeks off before the super bowl
this year
a lot of people are buzzing about that
why take
two weeks to let one of these teams
develop a coveted 19 issue
let's keep this thing rolling and my
guess is there are plenty of people at
the league office that were thinking
man if there was only a way we could
just play this damn game sunday and be
done with it
because who knows what's going to happen
over the next 13 days
yeah and we got no pro bowl they don't
need that anyway
but we don't have it this weekend they
could have played it this weekend but
obviously the schedule is predetermined
the super bowl was preset
no way really to to move this thing like
they probably want to
but in best laid plans absolutely they'd
want to play the game this sunday rather
than
wait another week and and uh the threat
of an outbreak
real quickly jay baz is josh mcdaniel is
ever going to be a head coach again if
it's not
in new england no
i don't know that it's going to be in
new england though i don't know
why would he have talked belichick boys
to the eagles
about what was one of the least
desirable jobs this cycle
if he thought he was going to get the
patriots job at some point unless bill
belichick really is going to go warren
buffett rupert murdoch and coach into
his 80s
but folks look we got to be realistic
about this and and george halas retired
from coaching when he did
for one very simple reason he couldn't
stand for three hours anymore
there will be a point where bill
belichick is not able to
physically accomplish the demands of the
job so what are you gonna do you're
gonna coach from the coaching box what
are you gonna do at that point so
i i don't think belichick is gonna be
there another ten years but
you know from a daniel's standpoint that
the the sun has set
on on his a-list status as evidenced by
the fact that
he interviewed with the eagles they seem
to be interested and they hire nick
ciriani instead
yeah and if mike if he ever gets an
opportunity he better take that job
because i think it will be his last
opportunity but i don't think he ever
gets another chance he turned down the
colts and that was his best
opportunity to go be a head coach
somewhere else and i'm with you i'm not
sure he gets the new england job
i think belichick is setting up one of
his sons to take over that job when he's
done
now what robert craft wants to do is a
completely different thing
but i think that would be what bill
belichick would want is one of his sons
to get that job
yeah robert kraft is setting up one of
his sons to run the team and
that son's got to be on board with the
son of belichick taking over the
patriots so
let's see how that all plays out but one
of those or both of those kids is going
to end up being a head coach somewhere
because
belichick and you're just going to
assume they know what they're doing and
also they have somebody they can call on
the phone
for advice anytime they want
you